the belarusian athlete christina
timorushkaia
has said that she feared she would be
sent to a psychiatric hospital or
jail after she publicly criticized her
coaches
poland gave the olympian a humanitarian
visa this is after belarus team
officials attempted to force her to
return early from tokyo
she's been speaking at a news conference
in warsaw today
when i was in olympic village some coach
and some
men from our team they come to my room
and they say that i should
say that i have some injury and come
back to home if i will
not do it then i can get some problem in
my country
and they don't know which one problem
but um
after this day they also come to my room
and they say that i have no chance to
run 200 meters and
i should to come back to home and it's
not their decision and
they just should to do it and when i
pick up my clothes and go to the car my
grandmother she called me and she said
you can't
come back to home because on the tv they
say a lot of
bad words about you that you have some
mental pro
problems and maybe you can go to the
some hospital in belarus or maybe to
jail we don't know
well skies moscow correspondent diana
magnay has been following the story and
joins us now so diana
belarus was clearly not an option for
this athlete to return to but how much
safer is she going to be in poland
well a lot safer than she would be if
she was in belarus i think it's very
clear that if she had gone back having
basically criticized her coaching team
on instagram
um she would have faced reprisals and we
could only guess what those would be
but they could be detention um
a possible trial on fabricated criminal
charges you know it's not something that
clearly she was prepared to do even
though this defection
essentially was not planned she made
very clear
it was something that she had to decide
based on these
threats that she got from her team then
in discussion with her parents back in
belarus with her husband
with her grandmother she made the
decision as they were
essentially driving her to the airport
that she would try and seek asylum with
the japanese police
rather than go back home but you see
there the nature of the threats made
against her and the way that belarusian
state tv propaganda went into overdrive
about
uh her supposedly having mental problems
and that's why
she would no longer be running in the
olympics
but we saw earlier in the week a
terrible incident
in kiev ukraine where a bella russian
activist was found hanged
the police are still investigating but
one of their possibilities is that this
was murder dressed up as suicide and
that is certainly what most of the
belarusian
diaspora believe that it was so
questions about the safety
of belarusians in exile are
you know it's not guaranteed any
belarusian living outside of belarus at
the moment does not want to tell me when
i speak to them where
exactly they are because it is clear
that alexander lukashenko the
president's
cohorts his security forces operate
beyond
belarus's borders but she is now in
poland she says she feels safe her
husband is on route from
kiev to join her and she says that the
polls are giving her
support in terms of pursuing her
sporting career that
fundamentally she is a sports person
she's never been interested in politics
that is not her priority
but that she is prepared to help in any
way that she can other
athletes in belarus who might find
themselves
in a similar situation uh but the person
that she was there in that press
conference
with a bella russian opposition
politician was keen to distance her from
the politics
but to make the point that what we're
seeing in belarus
at the moment is the worst political
repressions in europe than we've seen
since world war ii so it's no surprise
really
that she didn't want to go back home